- All right, everybody.
Let's close out with a
feel-good story we found online.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat jazzy jingle)
- A New York man is
combining his love of baking
with his compassion for kids
to do something very wonderful.
He sells these incredible
cookies, which smell so good,
to send hundreds of sick
children and their families
on dream vacations to theme
parks all over the country.
Super cool. We have him
on the line right now,
from Baking Memories 4 Kids,
everybody say hello to Frank,
watching on NBC New York!
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] What's up Frank?
- Hey Kelly! So good to
be on. Oh, thank you.
- Oh my gosh. Well, we love having you,
and this is such a beautiful
thing you're doing.
So this came from your
own experience, right?
- Yes. I was out west hiking.
I found a lump in my neck,
Kelly, and I flew home,
and I went to a bunch of
doctors and I had no idea.
They finally diagnosed it.
It was advanced stage
three testicular cancer,
and it was going into my brain.
So I did three months of aggressive chemo,
where I couldn't even walk up
a flight of stairs after a week.
But when I was getting
the chemo, I saw moms
and the kids also getting
chemo and suffering,
and I knew if I was able
to survive this cancer,
God gave it to me for a
reason and I would be able
to help families going
through what I went through,
and more importantly, the children.
- Aww.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- So you're feeling good?
You're feeling good now though?
- I am so great and I started
the nonprofit Baking Memories 4 Kids,
and we've been our 11th
season so far, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Wow. (audience
applauds and cheers)
So how exactly does it
work? Tell everybody.
- We bake cookies, and I've had a,
I have a swimming pool company
that I always used to bake these cookies
and give them to my customers.
And after I got sick, it
was, instead of making
a couple thousand cookies,
now we make millions.
To date, we've sold 4.1 million cookies,
and we make them lovingly
here, Kelly, on the weekends,
and we sell them online
and all of that money
goes towards funding, it's
a week-long, amazing trip
for the entire family, all expenses paid,
Universal Studios, every amusement park,
and Baking Memories pays
for the entire trip.
- [Kelly] That's incredible,
Frank, thank you so much.
Wait, I'm gonna taste
one because, well, I can.
Oh my God, I love that it's
crunchy. This is really good.
And I don't usually eat
cookies, so thank you.
Thank you, Frank. You have
such a beautiful heart.
Congrats on beating cancer as well, man.
That's, what a beautiful thing
that you went through something so tragic,
but you turned it around to
make it something beautiful
for others and yourself.
Wow. I'm loving your post right now.
Well, that's not all Frank.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show want to honor
truly unstoppable people
just like yourself.
So they're gonna be writing
Baking Memories for Kids
a check for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Awesome. Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Thank you so much, Frank.
Have a blessed holiday season.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Taraji P. Henson, Matt
Iceman, Killer Mike,
Laura Terry and the
Tanners, and our day of elf.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.